20,000 PEOPLE GETTING OUT OF THE
KABUL AIRPORT.
A HIGH NUMBER INDEED.
>> THAT IS AN ACCOMPLISHMENT.
JOINING US NOW IS FREELANCE
AFGHAN JOURNALIST, NAZEERA.
SHE HAS FACED THREATS FROM THE
TALIBAN HAVING COVERED THEM AS A
JOURNALIST THROUGHOUT THE 1990s,
AND RECENTLY SHE HAS BEEN
PRESSING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY IN STUDIO.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE
STILL IN AFGHANISTAN THAT YOU
ARE CONSIDERABLY WORRIED ABOUT
AND THAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM A
LOT OF AFGHANS.
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU?
>> SURE.
FIRST OF ALL, GOOD MORNING TO
YOUR AUDIENCE.
AFGHAN AUDIENCE, AND THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME.
GOOD QUESTION.
EVERYBODY KNOW AFGHANISTAN'S
SITUATION.
THEY DON'T NEED ME TO EXPLAIN
AGAIN.
BUT BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
MANY MANY AFGHAN PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT CATEGORY, THEY KEEP
CALLING ME, NIGHTTIME, DAYTIME,
24 HOURS, BUT I HAVE TO ANSWER
THEM.
SOME OF THEM, THEY ARE HIDING
THEIRSELF.
SOME OF THEM CALLING FROM THE
AIRPORT.
WOMEN CRYING, YOUNG GENERATION
ALSO CRYING.
THEY ASKED ME, HOW SHOULD I
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN.
THEY THINK THAT I AM SOMEBODY.
I TOLD THEM I'M NOT
EXTRAORDINARY PERSON.
JUST A JOURNALIST.
I JUST CAN'T RAISE MY VOICE
BECAUSE OF YOU.
THEY'RE CRYING, I'M CRYING WITH
THEM.
THAT'S WHY I LOST MY VOICE.
LOOK AT MY VOICE.
EVERY SINGLE MINUTE PEOPLE CALL
ME, AND THEY'RE CRYING, AND THEY
REMIND ME, 1996 WHEN I WAS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND I WAS YOUNG
JOURNALIST.
NOW, EVERYTHING REPEAT AND THEY
REMIND ME OF THE DARK TIME IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> IT REMINDS YOU OF THE DARK,
OF THE TIME IN AFGHANISTAN, AND
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE YOU'VE HEARD THE TALIBAN
TRYING TO PROJECT A MORE
MODERATE IMAGE, PROMISING THAT
THERE WON'T BE RETRIBUTIONS,
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN,
YOU KNOW, FACTS THAT CONTRADICT
THE PROMISES THAT THEY'RE
MAKING.
NO ONE REALLY KNOWS THE TALIBAN
LIKE YOU KNOW THE TALIBAN HAVING
COVERED THEM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THESE
PROMISES THE TALIBAN IS MAKING
AND WHAT THIS IS GOING TO MEAN
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> GOOD QUESTION.
I DOUBT IT BECAUSE TALIBAN IS
IDEOLOGY, HOW CAN CHANGE
SOMEONE'S IDEOLOGY.
TALIBAN IS THE SAME TALIBAN,
THEY PROMISE THEY ARE GOING TO
BE A MODERN TALIBAN.
IF IT'S THE NEW GENERATION, I
WOULD BE MORE HAPPY.
I GO TO AFGHANISTAN ONE DAY, AND
I, YOU KNOW, MAKE A REPORT FROM
MY BELOAVED COUNTRY, BUT I DOUB
IT.
I THINK IT'S TOO SOON.
TIME WILL SHOW THAT, BUT BASED
OFF MY EXPERIENCE, THE TALIBAN
SHOT WOMEN AT THE KABUL SPORT
STADIUM.
I HAVE SO MANY UNFORTUNATELY
NEGATIVE EXPERIENCE, BUT AS I
TOLD YOU, IT'S TOO SOON.
BUT IF THEY ARE REALLY KEEP
THEIR COMMITMENT, BECAUSE WE ARE
LIVING IN THE 21st CENTURY.
IT'S A DIFFERENT TIME, BUT I
HOPE SO.
WE SHOULDN'T LOSE THE HOPE, BUT
I DOUBT IT.
BUT STILL.
>> YOU REALLY BROUGHT THE HUMAN
ELEMENT OF THIS STORY TO THE
PENTAGON BRIEFING, WHICH CAN BE
SORT OF A STALE PLACE WHERE
INFORMATION IS CERTAINLY AND
IMPORTANTLY GRABBED BY
REPORTERS, BUT YOU BROUGHT THE
HUMAN ELEMENT OF THIS TO A
BRIEFING THERE THE OTHER DAY AS
YOU QUESTIONED ABOUT THE
DEPARTURE OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO
AMERICANS?
AMERICANS ABOUT THE PLIGHT OF
AFGHANS AND WHAT YOU WANT TO SEE
FROM AMERICANS?
>> YOU WANT ME TO CRY AGAIN?
IT WAS NOT MY VOICE.
IT WAS MILLION OF AFGHAN PEOPLE.
IT WAS MILLION OF KIDS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IT WAS NOT EASY.
THAT MOMENT WAS VERY TRAGIC,
VERY STRONG MOMENT FOR ME AS I
TOLD THEM, AS I ASKED THAT
OVERNIGHT TALIBAN ALL OF
AFGHANISTAN.
BUT I HAVE HOPE, BUT STILL I WAS
THINKING ABOUT I DON'T KNOW
WHICH INTERPRETATION ABOUT SHAR
YA LAW, WE KNOW HOW TO PRACTICE
OUR RELIGION.
I TOLD YOU, IT WAS VOICE OF
MILLION OF VOICELESS AFGHAN
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY AFGHAN WOMEN,
THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENT, MY BELOVED
COUNTRY, I WAS CRYING FOR MY
FLAG.
IT'S MY IDENTITY.
AFGHAN WOMEN HAS A LOT OF
ACHIEVEMENT, AND IT WAS, YOU
KNOW, I WAS THINKING ABOUT MY
CULTURE, AFGHANISTAN HAS A RICH
CULTURE.
I AM VERY STRONG JOURNALIST, BUT
IN THIS SITUATION, I LOOK SO
WEAK AND CRYING, OTHERWISE FOR
30 YEARS I WORK AS A
PROFESSIONAL JOURNALIST WITH
BBC, AND NOW I AM INDEPENDENT
PA
BECAUSE I WOULD LIKE TO BE A
VOICE OF MILLION OF AFGHAN
WOMEN.
AFGHAN WOMAN BRAVE, AFGHAN WOMAN
STANDING, STILL TRY TO FIGHT FOR
THEIR RIGHTS.
MY MESSAGES FROM THE UNITED
STATES, FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE
HOPE.
NUMBER TWO, I HAVE A MESSAGE TO
UNITED STATES LEADERS.
A LOT OF WOMEN IN AFGHANISTAN,
THEY ARE SLEEPING INSIDE THE
AIRPORT.
WHY THEY DON'T BRING THEM TO THE
UNITED STATES AND ARRANGE THEM A
VISA.
AS I TOLD YOU, I HAVE CONNECTION
WITH MANY MANY DIFFERENT
CATEGORY OF PEOPLE, FORMER
AMBASSADOR, FORMER TEACHER,
ENGINEER, DOCTOR, NURSE,
ORDINARY, AND EXTRAORDINARY
PEOPLE.
THIS IS MY HOPE.
THIS IS MY MESSAGE TO THE PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD, PEOPLE KNOW
ABOUT AFGHANISTAN, WHAT'S GOING
ON.
ALTHOUGH I'M HOPEFUL THE TALIBAN
PROMISED US THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO CHANGE, BUT YES.
UNITED STATES SUPPOSED TO KEEP
THE COMMITMENT.
I ASK PRESIDENT BIDEN A MONTH
AGO, AFGHAN WOMEN HAVE
EXPECTATION FROM YOU, WHAT IS
GOOD MESSAGE, WHICH I ASKED
YESTERDAY, I SAID ALL OF THIS
SITUATION, YOU CANNOT DO
ANYTHING, DO WE HAVE ANY MESSAGE
FOR AFGHAN WOMEN, AND SHE
COMMENTS, AND SHE COMMENTED, AND
SHE SAID WE WILL BE WITH AFGHAN
WOMEN BECAUSE AFGHANISTAN HAS
VALUABLE WOMEN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN IN
AFGHANISTAN, HE SAW KIDS SAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE A DOCTOR,
ENGINEER, THAT'S WHY WE
SUPPORTED THEM.
NOW THEY SHOULD CONTINUE.
THEY SHOULD CONTINUE.
>> I HEARD WHAT SHE SAID.
SHE SAID THEY WILL BE IN THEIR
HEARTS, WILL THEY BE ON THE
PLANES, RIGHT, THAT IS GOING TO
BE THE QUESTION HERE.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
COMING IN AND BEING THE VOICE OF
SO MANY PEOPLE.
WE SEE THEM IN THE PICTURES.
WE DON'T ALWAYS HEAR WHAT IS ON
THEIR MINDS, SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
I SAW YOUR EYES, YOU HAD
FEELING.
I THINK PEOPLE WHO BLAME ME
THAT'S WHY I CRYING.
>> W